go to the government
hello son there you go
Paul H what a tree thank you so much
oh yeah all right yeah I'm feeling
lonely out there Wow
shaking there's a second right thigh
we're gonna walk out and go is this the
bathroom like I didn't know everything
oh yeah I'm gonna bring out ladies and
gentlemen the director of dr. strange
Scott Derrickson hi thanks so much for
having us here in the 60s dr. strange
entered the Marvel comic universe
bringing a whole fresh new voice to the
to the world of Marvel Comics the comic
was an origin story it was full of very
mind trippy visuals and it was a left
turn in the Marvel Universe and film
we've made is all those things going off
the great creativity of Stan Lee and
Steve Ditko I want to introduce the rest
of the cast of Doctor Strange I don't
know how I what I did in a former life
to deserve this cast but here they are
Tilda Swinton Rachel McAdams
tilda swinton rachel mcadams
shoots out Ejiofor
mads mikkelsen
and Benedict more
okay welcome welcome cast of dr. strange
that is an entrance sorry other panels
this is how you do it
so just really quickly kind of going
down the line benedict just you're you
are very good at taking on iconic roles
this is something but how what does this
one feel like and how's the experience
been different for you joining this kind
of superhero universe and being an
extended part of all of this it's very
very different mean the scale of it is
just something else and I don't know I
feel a lot of the heavy lifting
obviously done by the comics and the
origin story some of which we've used
someone which we haven't is quite one
though but you know this is a fantastic
art that this character goes on from
somebody who seemingly in control of a
world that we recognize and very sort of
high in the pecking order confident with
it and then this chaotic mess of an
accident happens to him and it's a story
about he about him discovering that he
he doesn't know anything he's just at
the beginning of understanding what our
reality is really about and what's
beyond our reality and I don't know yeah
how it compares to other iconic
characters aren't really answer to a
question he's very very different for
anything else I've done before that
that's for sure and you have sister joy
an absolute joy from start to finish and
primarily like I said because of this
huge huge art that I got to play as an
actor so that was that was great really
enjoyable and Rachel as Christine you're
sort of the you're his kind of link to
humanity or his link to the to the world
still so what he tell us about that
relationship yeah yeah we live in the
real world him and I together and yeah
we were friendly by mystery mystery yeah
and and now we're more we're colleagues
for we're colleagues we work at the same
hospital together and I'm always trying
to get him to come and work in my unit
with me because he's one of those
talented surgeons on the planet so we
have kind of a fun dance we do and we're
still good friends and and I get to
watch him go through this hour
and I am no the Steven before and the
Steven after he goes on this
soul-searching journey so it's great for
Christine to see to see that excellent
and then she would tell it's more no for
people who are familiar people who are
familiar with the comics how would you
describe how this portrayal of that
character is a little bit is it diverged
in a way or is there anything what can
you say about him well they have a
really interesting relationship because
of course it's the it's part of their
the origin story and and so moto becomes
a real sort of mentor and sort of with
the ancient one sort of dealing with him
understanding this power and he's you
know Steven strange is very unique very
special and surprises I think everybody
there and so they go on this very
complex journey excellent tilda swinton
I love you so much
uh I love that you're real like I've
never seen you in person I love that
you're a real person uh I want to catch
you like a Pokemon I want to catch I
mean I'm aging I'm aging backwards just
standing next match ik I mean you I
could not think of anyone better for the
ancient well like how how does it
basically feel to be this person this
being that kind of controls the universe
and understands the universe you connect
with that right away I feel like he
means it's the character as the
character like being really ancient I
kind of know what that feels well you
know the truth is but any of us could be
the ancient one that's the amazing thing
about what is originally in the comics
you know who knows who will end up being
the ag-1
the ancient one is a is a tight core and
all the things the ancient one does and
passes on and teachers and teases other
people anybody can do
some people can do them better than
others and some people have got a
special kind of you know glowing light
above their head and the hm1 can spot it
but the ancient one is there kind of
pulling it all out of everybody and
there are a lot of people in Kamaraj who
are learning all this stuff and it's all
about inside you know what's inside so
it's like super super hippy I've in a
space that it's all inside I'm sorry
it's gonna mean a lot to everybody I
mean I'm gonna see it because I hope it
means something to me
excellent mats would you describe
yourself as a villain in this movie do
you think you're you think you're a
villain no I think I like all good
villains I have to believe in what they
do right I mean my character believes in
a better world in a better universe just
like some of the other characters that
just the thing there's a different path
to find this better world a better path
a much more beautiful path so no he's
definitely not the villain in the
classic sense
he's a believer even when you're smiling
I feel like you gonna murder me even
when you're smiling it almost seems like
more at that point I gotta stop smiling
no never stop Mads Mikkelsen better but
hashtag never stop smiling Mads
Mikkelsen
Benedict Wong this movie has not one but
two Benedict and it's Benedict Wong is
playing the character of Wong how does
this Wong differ from the version in the
comics well I think when I had my
one-on-one with Kevin we did discuss
that I wasn't really comfortable being
the manservant a banker and we're
bringing him to modern update and I'm
happily residing is the master of the
mystic arts and the drill sergeant
excellent so Scott is there anything
see ya we've brought a clip I'm going to
set up this this clip it's an actual
scene from the movie this is the first
time that Stephen strange dr. Stephen
strange who his hands are been injured
beyond repair
meets the ancient one the cast of Doctor
Strange let's got down Finn hey guys
okay
hey Chuck sorry oh my god wow that's
quite a big movie yeah
I've got I've got the strange shake back
again Wow thank you very much for H for
letting us watch that with you that was
amazing
it's incredible yeah it's incredible to
see it this way but thank you so much
for bringing any any last words before
you guys get out of here Scotty yeah
just the film comes out in November 4th
you'll see the complete thing then so
just quickly thank everyone I saw few
people last night what'd you do to make
all this as exciting as it is for all of
us is phenomenal and you know we can
only hope to please you with what we've
made with this film and it's all about
you guys so thank you for allowing us
here to show you a bit of it god bless
you
see you soon thank you thank you
Benedict Cumberbatch the cast of Doctor
Strange Scott Derrickson
cause
you